est ce que le futur de l'automobile ça
passerait pas par des voitures en
personnel individuel avec une seule
place un moyen d'attirer d'autres
derrière donc là vous l'avez en mode
cabriolet la mode rouge encore sport
derrière elle et ses patins rigolo et
puis là vous avez la bleue avec doubles
phares à l'avant alors je sais pas si ça
a réellement un intérêt mais en tout cas
c'est marrant je sais pas est ce que
vous savourez vous tenter d'avoir une
voiture que pour vous est ce qu'après un
côté un peu bizarre au moment où on
partage tous ont fait du catering là on
n'en fait pas on a sa propre bagnols la
marque c'est celle là c'est elektra
mécanique à cause que vous en pensez en
commentaire